foreign
I said no to you when you first asked me
out do you want to go to dinner with me
is because I'm moving to Brazil
[Music]
when I got there
was a lake there a lagoon
they told me not to go but
I didn't listen
she told me I had three wishes
when it falls off my wrist
those three wishes will come true
do not cut it
[Laughter]
demo
with me
all three of your wishes will come true
[Music]
would you even know there's no sun up in
the sky
if you crossed into a fairy tale
Storm is Coming there are portals in
this world
that we may never know we've trespassed
through
[Music]
I need to know where my wife is
people don't just disappear
which
You Don't See
but you will